okay okay here we go here we go this
technique could you the world
what school did you go to
so I went to Brandis then so yeah I with
the primary school yeah okay did we know
each other yeah
James hello yeah James yes me that's the
one what the [__] my best maker it up
and now you're talking to him honest
specs in he's like oh my god oh can we
not flip them and just get them out here
does he do
I wish I could say someone said here you
have to wear this with interest one
night as you do we were talking about
stuff and of course being circumcised I
said she said she said you're not
circumcised I said what do you mean
you've only know me a few all my life I
remember my mother telling me why
because it was fashionable at the time
she said you're not circumcised I said
that's ridiculous I should know if I'm
sorry conversation but the next day I
happen to be seeing my doctor my annual
physical of course
so while he was down there disagreement
I am circumcised because she says I'm
not and he goes it's a Shakespearean
right you went to the inauguration and
that was because you were first lady not
because you've been hominid right and
and you know I really tried to get out
of going
you know because I was going not as the
candidate or the opponent but as a
former first lady because the tradition
is presidents and former first ladies
all show up regardless a Republican or
Democrat to show support continuity of
our government so you know we we thought
okay maybe others aren't going so you
know we we called you called the bushes
and the elder bushes were in the
hospital which I think was legitimate
and so we were we were sitting there and
we were listening I was sitting next to
George W Bush and Bill was on my other
side and we were listening this really
dark divisive speech and it's reported
so I put it in the book it's reported
that George W Bush at as it ends says
that was some weird [__] I do
I'm on the edge glory and I'm hanging on
a moment of truth
Lori and I'm hanging on a moment
and as I read it I read about the
character that Ryan Ryan is Ryan Braun
the play and I said and I with great
enthusiasm I called up the producers and
I said this is great I can't wait to
give up and not a great part why don't
we see if we can get this is a great
part for Ryan Gosling
you do seem happy in your work good but
I like doing it
very good good I do break a lot of these
okay I mean I do break a lot of them but
my godson is getting his award and
that's your rap you're here somewhere oh
there you are you is that you oh yeah
well I think here over there but over
here stealing the Thunder is Garfield
and run so are you going to the Oscars
it was a ridiculous thing I said to Ryan
Reynolds if you win
kiss kiss me instead of your wife and
that's great
and the plan was is that he would kind
of move move towards his wife and then
it and then kind of last minute and then
he didn't win much to our disappointment
said to her I said to her we could still
just do it I must admit I didn't think
much of Graham Norton first time I laid
eyes on him look like a stiff breeze
could blow him over that was my first
impression of the man I could see why
some people took him for annoying he had
a walk and a talk that just wasn't
normal around here
and boy did he drink he drank like a man
without a care or worry in the world I
hope to finish this talk show one day I
hope Michael stops talking for just me I
hope people stop asking me to do stupid
boy so